purity pie a man with many talents
screaming bad handshakes hateful Norway
but also I have yet to reveal my
greatest talent
hold on ones hold on one second this is
going to be cool I mean I mean what
hello hallo hallo welcome my students
welcome to the put a pile of making
you're in the right place boy today I am
going to match you guys a love match I
know you guys are lonely sad pathetic
pieces of human beings you're single
you're sad I'm here to help you out your
boy Felix is here to help ya and if you
liked this video right now you got a
fifty five percent chance of winning an
Amazon gift card if you delete your
channel afterwards basically as you Bros
on Twitter if you need any help with
that some love you need a little help
with some love don't share you can talk
to me you want to go in the van and have
some sex I feel like this is a good look
for me I don't know I'd [ __ ] miss look
PewDiePie loved Goro here looking for
love single ready to mingle
post below and I'll hook you up with
someone don't worry it's safe I think
alright so here we go here we go ha ha
ha ha ha can you hook me up with Marzia
listen here you son of a [ __ ] I will
[ __ ] you in the ass
Isabelle when sell my my ferret it goose
what a great name of a ferret it's in
desperate need of a partner
I caught him for the fourth time in the
bathtub sowed in his tears this morning
he joined he enjoys taking a crap in the
corner that suits his need he has a
tampon fetish and he likes to 420 blaze
it when I'm not at home I've also seen
him read The Wall Street Journal on a
daily basis
this man this ferret needs a partner
goose is one year old but he has an old
soul please find someone for him so he
could fall out of his depression the
only thing that really seems to cheer
him up right now is when he sees sleepy
on my computer monitor well I mean it's
obvious yes yes I approve of the
marriage your goose can marry my
sleeping sleeping
will you marry good I actually don't
know if flippy is a boy or a girl are
you sexually attracted to this parrot I
love goose from the moment I said my
bulbous eyes upon him ferrets are my
bias another match has been settled and
I look after you guys I care about you
guys I'm not like all these other
youtubers they don't really care about
their fans also be sure to leave
subscribe to this channel and then a
comment I I am a Jeff Eric Alex knob
mister PewDiePie I'm looking for someone
that looks like Chef Ramsay and a little
bit of John Cena please my good sir
reload your vow that Cupid gave you what
the [ __ ] are you talking about Ramsay
and Cena honestly I can't it's not that
much different ah yes I see it now
you're welcome another happy cab all
right we have Ashley gallops ladies I
introduce Josh Clark coming in at
astonishing five feet six five foot six
he enjoys nothing more than long walks
on the beach legal highs and sweaty
thighs sweaty tights whatever getting
line leading it doesn't look good for
you I don't know what to say it doesn't
look good
I match you with
Silvia Kurobe gorgeo hi flan walks by
the beach match a man who can fist me
I'm sure Josh can can put out fist me
daddy Felix no no no no I'm I'm family
friendly
hey I don't fix anymore okay III slap
can someone treat me like one of his
friends girls I have red hair height one
set a perfect match and that will make
us a perfect match it's like not Indy
white and black but what we have is a
perfect match when you say this axis
that and family friendly Felix will [ __ ]
- boy yeah boy I'm good at this I think
I might be better at this than you -
moving on to the next satisfied customer
we have Justine Brooke Scott my name is
Justine I like dankmemes chicken wings
I'm a crazy cat lady and I'm anti-social
can you find me someone for a potato
like meep it's seems impossible doesn't
it but wait
scanning scanning
we have a man and Ray Calma hello I am a
simple average man who has the
possibility of brain damage because okay
now I'm gonna have to agree with you on
that one please hook me up this
wonderful things please hook up this
wonderful face and my hobbies are trying
to pretend I'm uh potato it's a perfect
match
damn I'm good at this smash that like
button for an Amazon get scars or I will
smash your mama I'm the love girl I can
do that [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] your bed I [ __ ]
anyone hell yeah I'm good you ever see
this face out on the nightclub boy you
better grab onto you lady tight and be
like hey girl I'm sorry we gotta go real
fast just family friendly Felix here
he's gonna [ __ ] your [ __ ] up but I would
like to stay ah ah ah ah ah hey moving
on these are all real comments these are
real people and the Magette named Jeff
everyone Christian Neil Nell Patterson i
sexually identify as a net Caracalla
[ __ ] round of applause you're a brave
you're a brave helicopter christian we
appreciate that you came
and four okay every night when my rotors
are slowing down as I begin to fall
asleep I wish for love but I have no one
to love or be loved why by pleasehelp
feelings Christian I'm a helper brother
I'm sorry I'm a help I'm a helper
chopper out I'm a helper chopper out I
got you
I know it might seem impossible for me
to find love for a helicopter but
scanning
the identity
bling-bling ring we have a match for a
helicopter are you serious Nora
Marie Hager I'm actually looking for a
vegan transgender are you atheist who
babes and CrossFit's
four times a week's four times a week
who's also a male feminist and
identified themselves as a Pastafarian
Apache helicopter my god
helicopter dog mega multi combo god
hyper of death and if you don't find
that you're an ignorant arrogant globe
lots of big sexist late
Nora Marie I have got you I got you girl
I don't know how helicopter babies are
made but I I imagine it's done by
underwater rats
please invest I'm looking for investors
I've started an underwater what rats
business on the side
moving on yo one years old single cook
cockatiel looking for that special ten
in my lap yes I'm a vinyl but I can
still be the color in your last baby let
me smash a bird comes to me for love
advice that's right bamm-bamm I got you
Kaylie how I hook you up with hailing
cab
hello I am a male burp about five inches
tall gray pearl and have a mohawk I'm
two years old I enjoy screaming in the
mornings and fight with my reflection I
need a woman who will enjoy our seed
feet and scream with me at the crack of
dawn you're welcome a perfect match a
love love meets love
[Music]
I'm sorry so beautiful seeing I have the
best job these birds are gonna look
happy to die knowing I made a positive
impact
[Music]
you